I actually may have a warrant for your
arrest let me in your house no where's
your gold if you don't tell me where
your gold is I'm going to take you to
jail all right I have a warrant for your
arrest tell me where your Bitcoin is wow
we think you do okay go look for it well
they're not gonna find my gold either of
course they can't they can of course
they can they can look so they can't
it's physical and it exists well isn't
isn't your Bitcoin stored on something
physical you have like a flash drive or
even if you wrote down your seed phrase
on a piece of paper it's not on this
piece of paper it's in my head oh your
whole your whole seat phase is in your
head yes
media personality he's the CEO of Euro
Pacific asset management and the founder
of Chef gold he's also one of the
biggest critics of Bitcoin which is
exactly why we're here today we first
clashed back in February earlier this
year on Fox News where we debated
Bitcoin versus gold so here we are ready
for round two Peter Schiff welcome thank
you so much for joining me today how are
you doing well I'm I'm doing all right
thanks for coming to visit me yeah
absolute pleasure like I said we clashed
heads back in February so there's some
stuff that we disagree on but there is a
lot that we do agree on and that's where
I want to start
so would it be fair to say that you are
against money printing you are somewhat
anti-government and very pro-free
Enterprise capitalist yes and and if
you're in favor of Freedom by definition
you're you want to minimize the size of
government because government is really
the antithesis of freedom because
government takes away some of your
rights uh government has power they have
Monopoly on Force so if you have
government that you know fulfills its
legitimate function which is just the
protection of life and private property
and to help you secure your rights then
a limited government can be a force for
good because it's possible that having
government can lead to Greater freedom
and greater Prosperity but the problem
is governments rarely stay small once
you create a government and you give it
some power that power corrupts and the
government gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and then the government causes
more harm than it does good and I think
pretty much every country in the world
government has already grown beyond the
point where it's a positive force and
it's become a negative force and so the
world would be much Freer and much more
prosperous if we had a lot less
government freedom is a keyword right
now especially because of everything
that we've seen over the last two years
so what was the
feu in terms of the lockdowns and you
know the mandatory medicines is that
really sort of does that go against your
your beliefs in terms of how big or how
small a government should be well
absolutely I mean all these governments
force people to stay at home they force
businesses to close
supposedly because it's for the public
good
but
we're supposed to be a free people and
we don't act for the collective good of
society we we act for our own individual
good and we make our own choices and if
you believe in that that's how you have
the most prosperity for everybody I mean
the whole collectivist idea that mindset
that the individual needs to be
sacrificed for some greater group good
that has never worked that has always
led to misery I think what should have
happened with covid is people should
have been free to make their own
decisions if people wanted to wear masks
they could wear masks if they wanted to
take a vaccine they can get a vaccine if
some businesses wanted to stay open they
could stay open to some customers wanted
to go to those businesses they could
employers employees everybody is free to
negotiate their own decisions and you
know I think if you look at countries
that maybe were closer to that like
maybe Sweden I mean Sweden didn't have
any of the lockdowns that we had yet you
know and so they didn't have to bear the
cost
and the Swedish people are fine and and
if you look at all the inflation that
were experienced and today a lot of it
not all of it because the the
inflationary seeds were sown a long time
before coven but we poured a lot of
water on them during covid because it
was the worst combination of monetary
and fiscal policy I've ever seen and I
called it out in real time back in March
of 2020 when they unveiled the policy
they told everybody not to go to work
and they they ordered all the factories
shut but then they wanted everybody to
keep on spending well how do you keep on
spending when you're not producing and
so the government just printed a bunch
of money and said here here's the money
spend this and a lot of people were
given two or three times more money than
they earned when they were working
except when they were working they were
productive they were contributing to the
economic uh pot
but when they stopped working they were
contributing nothing but they were given
all this money to try to take out of the
pot and so money supply exploded as
Goods production collapsed and their
their consequences were obvious back
then prices would go way up which is
exactly what's happened and you have
politicians trying to blame it on covet
or blame it on Supply chains that's not
why we have inflation it's all the money
that's been created uh by central banks
supposedly uh to keep the economy out of
recession while they were locking
everybody down but if the politicians
want to lock people down then they have
to be willing to allow a recession to
happen I mean you can't avoid it if you
tell people to stop working and stay at
home the economy is going to have a
recession you can't try to paper that
over by creating inflation but that's
what they did so they printed
unprecedented amounts of money
um quantitative easing as we celebrated
the last two years so in your opinion
why is that bad and also
if you know that it's bad why don't they
know that it's bad I don't know maybe
they knew and they didn't care I mean
the problem in the United States is the
U.S economy is so screwed up it's so
fundamentally flawed we have so much
debt we can't really survive a real
recession and and so the FED felt it had
no choice but to pump the economy full
of money because nobody had any savings
nobody was going to be able to stay at
home and miss a paycheck they couldn't
pay their rent they couldn't pay their
mortgage the whole financial system
would implode because everybody was
living paycheck to paycheck so how do
you take away everybody's paychecks when
that's all they've got but that should
have been a reason not to lock down the
economy maybe they should have thought
you know what we can't afford to do this
so let's just take our chances with
covid
and but you know because they thought we
had a free lunch that hey we could just
send everybody home because we've got
the FED that can just print money
they maybe they didn't understand that
you could print a lot of money but that
doesn't mean that money is going to buy
anything
the key is to produce stuff what gives
money value is the stuff that's produced
at least Fiat money paper money I mean
you have to be able to buy stuff with it
so if you just print money that's not
connected with any productivity the
money has no value or at least the value
goes down and the price goes up so
prices have to adjust to this increased
quantity of money and that's what we're
seeing and the adjustment is really just
getting started we're going to have some
serious price increases in the next
several years regardless of central
banks raising interest rates and most of
these central banks that are raising
interest rates are going to keep
printing money and even though they're
raising interest rates the rates are
still low that the ECB raise rates today
75 basis points up to one and a half
percent their inflation rate is nine and
a half percent that's negative eight
percent interest how is that going to
stop inflation meanwhile they're still
printing euros but they're not printing
nearly as many as the FED is printing
dollars so the whole world look at
what's happening in Japan everybody is
flooding their economy with paper and so
prices have to go up there's no way to
stop it I ask everyone this because then
we talk about this you know it just
sounds so obvious supply and demand
right but what I don't understand is why
they do it is it destruction by Design
does it benefit those at the top are
they trying to push people deeper into
poverty through inflation what's your
take well I think they do it because
they think it's better than the
alternative of not doing it because
politicians their main goal is to get
reelected that is the fundamental
problem with any kind of democracy is
that that the leaders just want to get
reelected
and if your re-election depends on
getting 51 of the vote
um you basically have to bribe the
electorate I mean 51 of the people are
not that bright right you know they're
not going to understand economics so
they're just going to vote for whoever
promises them something for nothing
right they don't understand that there
is no free lunch they did they just want
whatever they can get for free that's
why the United States was you know
formed as a republic our founding
fathers tried their best to protect us
from the evils of democracy it worked
for a while and the country prospered
when democracy was kept in check but now
it's kind of run amok and it has all
over the world so when politicians want
to give out free stuff they don't want
the public to know that they have to pay
for the free stuff so they don't want to
have to raise taxes so they want to say
here's some government program I'm
giving you education I'm giving you
health care I'm giving you housing or
whatever it is they're going out they
don't want to say oh but I got to raise
your taxes to cover the cost so they
want to print the money to cover the
cost uh and so they pay for spending
through inflation but then when prices
go up as a result of the inflation the
governments create to pay for their
programs now they look for a scapegoat
oh well we have all this inflation
what's causing this what could it be it
must be greedy businessmen that are
gouging the consumer maybe it's this man
man Putin yeah look at it Putin is
jacking prices up it's Putin's price
hikes I mean they're always going to try
to blame somebody else for the inflation
that they create I mean even today uh uh
um at the press conference
um legard said that the inflation is
caused by Supply Supply problems as if
the ECB monetary policy of negative
interest rates and quantitative easing
have absolutely nothing to do with it
just pure coincidence it's all just
Supply problems and the same thing uh
pal whenever Powell talks he he never
accepts responsibility for creating
inflation he's always looking for some
external cause that's got nothing to do
with their own monetary policy when the
actual definition of inflation is an
expansion of the money supply so if
that's what inflation is how can the
source be anything other than the
central banks that are in charge of the
money supply
sounds so simple yeah yeah we are it's
unbelievable actually um so I'm
interested to know to what extent would
you like to see the government involved
in our lives politically and
economically very small I mean small
enough to drown in a bathtub is what
they say but no I mean you just need
government to secure your rights that's
all I mean if you look at America in the
19th century
total government spending was less than
I think four percent of GDP I mean
that's tiny
and and now it's it's enormous you know
I I recently took took a look because I
you know I watched you know this speech
that uh president
um uh Biden gave in Philadelphia you
know where the Declaration of
Independence was signed and he made many
references to the Declaration of the
pens of course he he missed the most
important ones he kept saying all men
are created equal or he was saying but
he missed the essence of it and and why
we have government which is to secure
Liberty and and property
but you know the Declaration of the
Penance the the the motivating factor
for uh the colonists who want to rebel
against you know your your your your
country right your King King George was
taxation right now you know they were
saying taxation without representation
but they objected to the taxation well
if you look at the amount of taxes
that Colonial Americans paid to the king
it was about one to one and a half
percent of their annual income that's it
and they were objective they had a
revolution
because they were paying one one and a
half percent and the King was taxing
Britain a lot higher than the colonies I
mean colonies got a good break but even
in Britain I think the subjects at that
time that were living in the United
Kingdom were paying about five or six
percent of their income in taxes to the
king I mean wouldn't the British love to
go back to a monarchy and just have to
pay five percent tax sounds pretty good
I mean now you have Brits paying 40 50
60 tax no king of England ever could
have gotten away to doing to British
citizens what they're doing to
themselves through a democratic process
they were better off with less democracy
and more freedom yeah that absolutely
blows my mind especially what we're
talking about earlier with with the
queen and who could potentially take
over after her um but I watched all I'm
the one percent let's talk
um video it's a for those that don't
know it's an hour and a half video on
YouTube where you basically debated
um the Occupy Wall Street protesters
um anti-catalists socialists
um and it was it basically was like you
were the only sober person at a drunk
party with all these people screaming in
your face that's what it looked like so
firstly amazing endurance I don't know
how you have the patience for that but
I'm interested why did you go down there
to do that and how did you even have the
endurance for the patient well first of
all it wasn't really a debate it was
more of like an argument
but it was also I was also trying to be
educational but to be honest with you my
audience wasn't
the people in zuccotti park I mean I I
hope that I could get through to some of
those guys but my real audience was that
I knew people would be watching it and I
originally came there with reason and
that's where it originally got posted on
the reason website
and and so but the whole purpose of my
going down there because I saw this
protest movement and the protest was all
about the financial crisis and blaming
it on Wall Street and so these
protesters were down on Wall Street
protesting the bailouts and everything
that happened and I went down there kind
of to express some solidarity for their
anger and their being upset at these
Wall Street bailouts and the financial
crisis but I just wanted to redirect
their anger to the proper place which
was Washington I wanted the protest at
the foot of the Federal Reserve right
that or congress that's where the
bailouts emanated I mean you can't blame
a big bank for taking a bailout I mean
why wouldn't you I mean if the
government offered you money who's going
to be dumb enough to refuse it the
problem is the government shouldn't have
offered it in the first place and I was
very much against all the bailouts from
the beginning and of course the Fed
Reserve never should have pursued that
Reckless monetary policy following the
bursting of the.com bubble they lowered
interest rates to one percent and
inflated a housing bubble and then it
was the government that guaranteed all
these mortgages is creating all the
moral hazard so the housing bubble
that inflated and the financial crisis
that ensued when it popped
it was not created by
Wall Street but by the government and by
the Federal Reserve so I wanted
um these people to understand that and
and and and point their anger in the
right direction but I also wanted to
show them that if they really want
Prosperity if they really want a better
life
government is not where you're going to
get it right there's all these examples
of governments all around the world that
made a bunch of promises about just give
us more power and and you'll live better
and everybody always gets burned if you
get into bed with the government you
know exactly what's going to happen to
you if you want freedom and prosperity
if you don't like your lot in life and
you'd like to have a higher standard of
living you need capitalism to do it
capitalism is the only Force that's
going to lift people out of poverty and
and because capitalism is all about
Freedom you know and you can't succeed
in a capitalist system without helping
other people succeed too I mean that's
the beauty of capitalism that's the
invisible hand that you know Adam Smith
wrote about that in The Wealth of
Nations around the same time that we had
the the Declaration of Independence
um but you know government can take your
money right government has a gun and
they can put you in jail and they can
take your money whether you want to give
it to them or not yep but a businessman
can't take your money he has to earn
your money he has to convince you to
give him your money well if I'm a
businessman how do I convince you to
give me your money well I offer you
something that you value more I produce
a product that you want I provide a
service that you want and then you
voluntarily exchange your money so if I
want your money I have to win it over I
have to give you something that you
prefer to the money and so everybody
gains in that transaction and it's only
private capitalism free market
capitalism where individuals through the
pursuit of their own self-interest end
up helping everybody and that's how you
create living standards that's how you
or raise living standards you have more
production you have you know businesses
are formed capital is formed increasing
the productivity of Labor and so now
there's more goods and services to
consume so the way out of poverty is the
free market so I wanted these people to
know that they were there demanding more
government they needed to demand less
government get government out of their
way so that they can have the higher
standard of living that they want okay
so here's the thing I agree with
everything that we've discussed
everything that you said
um I'm very pro-freedom very Pro small
government
and I personally think Bitcoin is the
answer to everything that we've
discussed and so many people share this
with you I know you obviously don't so
Peter I feel like this is exactly where
the debate begins so tell me what is the
problem with Bitcoin as you guys know
I'm a huge advocate of taking
self-custody of your crypto so the
hardware wallet which I use and want to
recommend to you is called tangent it's
an elegant card checked wallet that
perfectly fits into your card holder all
you have to do is just tap the card to
your phone for Activation the private
key is generated on the chip of the card
and then copied to one or two additional
cards for backup so if it gets lost
you'll still be able to access your
funds using a backup card the Chip And
side of the card has been certified to
eal 6 Plus standard this is the highest
security level you'll find in U.S Air
Force or NASA's systems also the chips
firmware has been audited by a Swiss
company called kadelski security which
found no backdoor no malicious or
suspicious elements unlike most Hardware
wallets tangent is durable fully
waterproof and dust proof there are no
failure prone elements like a battery
all you need is the Tantrum card and
your phone there's no need to worry
about losing your mobile device it's
just a display so if anything happens to
it you simply take another smartphone
install the tangent app tap the card
enter your password and make instant
transactions with over 6 000 different
cryptocurrencies tangent doesn't collect
any of your data and also they can't see
any of your assets their open source app
is available on GitHub for inspection
this also means that if anything were to
happen to tangent as a company you still
would be able to access your funds oh
overall tangent is a very secure
Hardware wallet it's easy to use and
it's affordable you can order your
wallet from tangent's official website
and get a 10 discount with my promo
codes layer or just click on the link in
the description below oh Bitcoin has a
lot of problems I mean the only problem
Bitcoin would solve is if you have too
much money and you want to lose some you
could buy Bitcoin and that will solve
your problem these are sound bites no
this is reality look
Bitcoin the idea of Bitcoin is nice and
if you don't really understand what
money is uh you may be fooled into
thinking Bitcoin is a viable alternative
but but it's not I mean
Bitcoin
tries to copy
the properties that that that made gold
better money than some other commodity
it's divisibility it's it's portability
it's fungibility
um yes I mean Bitcoin does a good job if
if you cut a Bitcoin in half right each
half is the same just like if I take an
ounce of gold and I make two half ounces
they're they're identical all gold is
exactly the same right uh it's not like
if if you have two cows they're not
going to weigh the same they're not
going to you know be the same height you
know even two diamonds are not going to
be the same they have different cut
Clarity color stuff like that but Gold's
gold and so it's fungible divisible it
it's really good as a medium of exchange
and a unit account and all that but
what Bitcoin doesn't have is any actual
value right it does like gold does gold
is a commodity it's a metal here I mean
I have some gold in this watch
um but so gold gold actually has value
that can be stored and since gold
doesn't tarnish or Decay it makes it
ideal as a long-term store of value
because I can have gold and in 100 years
somebody could use that gold for
something it's not going to go away and
and so gold was a great commodity to be
money because what money is is the most
marketable commodity so be in order to
become money you have to start out as a
commodity and then you can become money
now you also have Fiat money which a lot
of people that are pro-bitcoin
understand the problem with Fiat money
and the way Fiat money came around is
uh governments or not even before
governments private issuers
uh would hold real money gold in a vault
and then they would issue a note that
was backed by that goal that would
circulate
as a repo as a substitute for gold and
those notes were currency but what gave
the currency value was the goal that was
in a vault somewhere backing it up but
it was more convenient to trade in the
currency than in the in the actual gold
but what happened later on is currency
started to circulate because of
government that was backed by nothing
and it just derived its value from Faith
people just believed that it would have
value despite the fact it was no longer
tied to anything of real value like gold
so what Bitcoin really is like is like
that fiat currency that a government
craves where it has no actual value but
if people have confidence in it if
people believe that it has value well
then it will have some value temporarily
until people stop believing but in the
meantime
even though there are people who believe
that Bitcoin has value
the Bitcoin itself is so volatile in
price and so expensive to to transact in
that it's it can't even function as a as
a unit of account or as a medium
exchange and it can't be a store of
value so it doesn't even have any of the
characteristics that would be required
to making money it's it's just a
speculative token and the price can
change based on the mood of buyers and
sellers and eventually I think the price
zeros out that's all I'm guess is where
it's value comes from a lot of people
say that Bitcoin doesn't have any value
and I think they they land there because
they don't really understand how a
Bitcoin is created so I'm gonna just go
through the steps if I may where and
show you what I personally think okay
the value comes from and you can tell me
what you think okay so miners all around
the world use hard Capital to purchase
electrical energy whether that's Fiat um
you know dollars pounds whatever it is
they use hard Capital to purchase
electrical energy
that electrical energy is then converted
into computational Power using the Asic
mining Machinery so specific Bitcoin
mining Machinery so we now have
computational power that computational
power the Asic miners then harness that
computational power and put it into hash
power
that hash power
is then used to secure and validate the
network so once the network is secured
and validated there's a block reward and
the self-regulating network spits out
Bitcoin so right now it's 6.25 Bitcoin
so what happened was money went in
actual hard Capital went in and as a
result Bitcoin is created yes I I can
see that a lot of energy and resources
are wasted creating nothing because
situated something no they didn't okay
so what if I went out there and I hired
a group of people
to dig a big hole in the ground
right
spent a lot of money people worked
really hard digging that hole then I
paid the same group people to fill the
whole back up with the same dirt that
they dug out and at the end of the day I
I was right back where I started from
but a lot of work went into that right I
spent a lot of humans were digging and
filling and all that
but what have I accomplished what have I
created a value
well adult Hall is just a duh you can't
do anything with it Bitcoin has utility
what what utility decentralization it's
one of the most secure networks in the
world you have hundreds of thousands of
minors yeah but what but what's the
Bitcoin itself worth it's worth whatever
the market values well that right but
how do you know the Market's going to
Value it at anything in the future well
of course it will because of the value
of it what value what can I do but it's
one of the most secure networks in the
world we earlier you spoke about um the
confiscation of money so the fact that
you can actually hold Bitcoin but what
are you securing I mean I could have the
most Secure Vault in the world but if
I've got nothing inside it what good is
all that security if I'm not protecting
anything of value there is no value that
you have with that token now if that
token were let's say back by gold right
let's say there was a vault that had
some gold in it and then there was a
digital token that was issued instead of
paper right that was backed by gold I
had a digital token that was backed by
gold that was every bit as divisible and
portable and fungible as Bitcoin except
it actually had something backing it
something of real value that can
accomplish everything that you're hoping
to accomplish with Bitcoin except it
would work it could actually be a unit
of account a medium of exchange and a
stored value and a viable alternative to
Fiat money
so let me try paint it in in this in
this way so I think the that Bitcoin is
basically an energy business right try
tell that try tell that to the mind is
that it had to know that it has no value
so an example how is it an energy
business because I so I know a company
that put down eight thousand dollars in
and as a result it spits out Bitcoin
right and so if you tell them that it
has no value well they've just put down
eight thousand dollars so if I say to
them can I take your Bitcoin for free
they'll say absolutely not I technically
paid eight thousand dollars for it can I
give you an iPhone as an example so say
you have an iPhone right and you paid a
thousand dollars for the iPhone and I
say to you can I please have that iPhone
for free are you gonna give it to me for
free
well why would I right I know you paid
because you paid one thousand dollars
for it
that's true why would you give it to me
free so if I then said to you do you
know what it's second hand I'll actually
take it for 750 so now because of market
conditions and supply and demand
obviously as you know the price could
fluctuate like it can with get with with
gold with Bitcoin and any other but the
thing is right but it's the cell phone
actually has value I can use it make
calls I can you know surf the Internet
but if I was dumb enough to overpay
let's say I paid somebody a million
dollars and they gave me their their
their their phone I mean I'd be an idiot
to pay a million dollars but doesn't
mean I'm gonna find a bigger fool that's
gonna pay me two million dollars for
that phone but that's really what's
going on with Bitcoin I mean the people
who are buying Bitcoin or producing
Bitcoin yes I agree they're spending a
lot of money to acquire or create that
Bitcoin because they think they'll be
able to sell it to somebody who will pay
more and they do for now but you don't
know look as we're talking right now
Bitcoin is about nineteen thousand
dollars a coin now at one point it was
sixty nine thousand dollars a coin uh so
there were people who bought Bitcoin at
69 000 under the impression that they
were buying a safe haven store of value
and what they're down 70 right now on on
that I mean
I mean that's a bigger decline than just
about anything I mean you could probably
find some individual tech stocks that
went down more than Bitcoin
uh but there's nothing safe there's
nothing secure there's no values being
stored there but Bitcoin is 19 000 now
who's to say that a year from now it
won't be nine thousand or one thousand
you you don't know I mean maybe it'll go
up I think it's more likely to go way
down than go up
but something that can be that volatile
and have such a big move in such a short
period of time I mean I I don't I don't
see how anybody would have confidence in
it as as as as a substitute for money
so let's talk about that as a sort of
value
um so gold
um in the last five years his own is
only up 35
Bitcoin in the last five years is up two
thousand percent
um gold in the last 10 years is up three
percent Bitcoin in the last 10 years is
up 375
000 I personally have a long time for
you um you know it's only uh 10 12 13
years old it's very new so I'm not
surprised that it's gonna fluctuate like
this
um but in the next I think it's going to
even itself out in the next 15 to 20
years look you could have made the same
argument about beanie babies in Gold if
you go back for the first few years of
Beanie Babies you could say well Beanie
Babies are a better store of value than
gold look how much they've outperformed
gold uh as the bubble was inflating
Bitcoin is one of the biggest bubbles in
the history of the world and obviously
as the price of Bitcoin went from
pennies to you know tens of thousands it
outperformed everything right yeah if
you would have bought Bitcoin 10 years
ago home run even if you bought it five
years ago you made a really good amount
of money but the majority of people who
own Bitcoin are losing money that is a
fact most people who own Bitcoin paid
more than nineteen thousand dollars and
in fact a lot of people who bought
Bitcoin lower bought more higher and
their average price is now above the
current Marketplace look at some of
these big promoters look at Michael
Saylor look at how much money his
company has lost billions of dollars
look at that fool in in
um
um El Salvador look how much money that
poor country has lost already in Bitcoin
and they're going to lose even more so
yes you had this huge speculative run-up
in Bitcoin but that's not a store of
value that's just a speculative gain and
the only people who benefited from that
are the people who sold the people who
are holding on haven't made anything
they're hoping the price goes back up
but the price is more likely to go back
down in fact if you look at what
happened to Bitcoin in 2021
that was the peak of the bubble right
think about all the money that was spent
by the crypto industry to pump up
Bitcoin and other altcoins in 2021.
massive uh commercials every Network
Billboards stadiums Super Bowl ads
conferences look at all the nfts you
know El Salvador came out I mean it was
it was one crazy thing after another
massive hype all the celebrities got on
board uh you know the athletes uh the
the the singers
um massive pump yet the price went down
you you drive through my neighborhood
drive around my street half these houses
are owned by crypto people they came in
here last year
they paid 40 million dollars for houses
in the street Crazy Prices eight times
what I paid for my house right a couple
years old why they were cashing out of
their crypto all the big money as they
were running all these commercials about
how great crypto was and Bitcoin what
were they doing they were selling that's
why the price didn't go up decided
despite unprecedented pumping all this
these institutions supposedly came in
might not uh um not Michael Saylor but
um uh Anthony scaramucci skybridge funds
those funds are down look at all of his
funds they're down 60 70 80 percent the
people that poured in their money are
killed and I think that was the the peak
of a Mania
um you know people are just in denial
right now it's a massive bear market
look at the technicals look at the chart
it's a complete disaster so I can't wait
till I was conversation again in five
years because I think you're gonna be
wrong so I want to make clear that there
is a difference between Bitcoin and
crypto that's really important that's
what the Bitcoin maximalists say so I'm
going to start with I'm going to start
with limited Supply 21 million that's
really important there will need to be
because we know there's a hard cap
that's really important you you know you
were talking earlier about printing
money with gold we never really know how
much gold there is that you there's
always there's not that much of it
there's always more to be found so I
think yeah a little bit more just
exactly with Bitcoin there's a hard cap
of 21 million if nobody wants Bitcoin it
doesn't matter how many there are there
can be one Bitcoin and it has no value
if nobody wants it so I want Bitcoin I
want Bitcoin because when we because
when the government came and said you
know if you don't take well if you don't
take on mandatory medicines that you
know take our injections then we're
gonna freeze your your bank accounts I
need to know that I have money that's
immune but it's not money but it is
money because I pay people in Bitcoin
and they pay me in Bitcoin business in
Bitcoin I got paid today I got paid um
all the way from Hong Kong so in a
country which is under you know the
Chinese the China communist regime they
were able to send Bitcoin to me they
didn't send gold to me across borders
they didn't send fiat currency to me
they were actually able to send me
Bitcoins they came to me instantly it
cost 58 cents I then sent that Bitcoin
to another country in the United Kingdom
I sent it to England it cost me 58 cents
incredible it doesn't matter my people
that work for me what are they gonna do
with it they can do so much with it
you mentioned great let's talk about
that right
right now no no no no creating
intermediary payment rails they allow
you to top up your card and then spend
your Bitcoin
I can't take this off and get a cup a
cup of coffee
you understand how it works you're
topping up your card with dollars what
you're doing with those schemes is you
take your Bitcoin and sell it and then
they load up your debit card with
dollars with Euros it doesn't matter but
yes it does because it still allows
Bitcoin to be used I can pop up my I
can't top up anything I can sell
anything and put the proceeds on it on a
debit card right
there not this gold bracelet what do I
do with this gold bracelet if I want to
go buy a cup of coffee what do I do you
wouldn't buy it you wouldn't buy a cup
of coffee with your gold bracelet right
but I can't buy Bitcoin but you can also
have a token backed by gold and use that
to buy your coffee and you can always do
it a token where there's well there's
several specialized exchange which can
be frozen if I don't have the correct
political opinion no on the same
exchanges that you people buy Bitcoin or
can be you know a a exchange you know
peer-to-peer the way you exchange
exchange your Bitcoin look Bitcoin is
not acceptable to these coffee shops or
grocery stores or gas stations no they
don't in New Hampshire and in the United
States they do in Malta they accept
Bitcoin um you people have bought houses
with Bitcoin you don't even accept
Bitcoin no you don't understand how it
works we don't the way shift gold sells
gold people have Bitcoin they use this
company called bitpay bitpay sells the
Bitcoin to get dollars and then they use
the dollars to buy the gold so there has
to be a buyer for those Bitcoin in order
for you to sell them to buy something
else when there's no buyer for Bitcoin
the bottom drops out of the market
because there is no natural demand for
Bitcoin because Bitcoin isn't used for
anything it's a payment it's a no it's
not of exchange it's a it's a medium no
it's not it's divisible by 100 who cares
that it's divisible and you know
anything because because at the whole
sale at the point of sale I can't take
my gold my goals
you don't have to figure out how much it
is you know how much what's the value do
you realize that the world was using
gold as money for thousands of years you
think and you think people were working
walking around with saws sawing off
their gold of course not and now with uh
the internet with blockchain and with
other technology we have your gold can
sit and evolve and it can circulate
without you ever having to touch it so
gold is going to work much better as
money today than it did in the 19th
century the 18th century the 17th
century or thousands of years before
that I mean gold still works you don't
have to try to reinvent the wheel when
the wheel still works and by the way
Bitcoin is in a wheel so you you know
it's not going to work at all but I
wanted to get back to your 21 million
um as if that's some kind of small
amount right well each Bitcoin
just represents an arbitrary quantity of
satoshi's so one Bitcoin is one million
100 million so there's 2.1 quadrillion
satoshi's our Satoshi scarce there's 2.1
quadrillion of them are they scarce well
that's 21 million Bitcoin no but who
cares oh no it doesn't matter 21 million
Bitcoin I don't need a whole Bitcoin
I'll just buy a Satoshi and I'm in there
great so this 2.1 quadrillion of those
now the thing is see people's limited
Supply and that's what matters I don't
need a whole Bitcoin I could do just as
much with one Satoshi as I could do with
one Bitcoin which is nothing because one
Bitcoin has no value and neither do the
Satoshi so it doesn't matter if I have
2.1 quadrillion or just one well
bitcoin's value right now is nineteen
thousand dollars no that's it no that's
its price right so you have to
understand the difference between price
and value okay right and price is what
you pay value is what you get so you can
pay a high price but not get a lot of
value like I said I can I can I can
offer to buy your bracelet for a million
dollars I mean if I offered you a
million dollars for your bracelet you'd
take it right I don't know it's my
grandma's can you make it oh well maybe
we'll make well how about your shoes
yeah right well am I going to get just
because I paid you a million dollars for
those shoes does that mean I own a
million dollar pair of shoes I think
that's a very surface way of looking at
it right now I totally agree with you
that a lot of people are looking to make
quick money because they don't
understand the value of it but there is
no value to understand the value is that
it's non-confiscatable money the most
secure network in the world
decentralized oh wait a minute first of
all people have had their Bitcoin seized
I mean criminals governments have seized
Bitcoin people who are dumb enough to
hold it incorrectly on centralized
exchanges where you would hold the
tokenized gold so I would never Advocate
ever for holding your Bitcoin or your
gold tokens on a centralized exchange
always hold it in a non-custodial way
that way it can never be seized they try
to do it in Canada they literally
reached out to companies who provide the
non-custodial software wallets or um
Hardware wallets they said can we have
the names and the addresses of those
people that own those funds can we have
them and they say we can't we can't stop
it it starts by Design
nothing in the world but if nothing in
the world is the same as that right but
if you if you exchange your Bitcoin
right there's going to be some kind of
record of it they'll be able to track
you down there's some kind of imprint on
the blockchain where the coins have gone
from one wallet to another don't do that
and the eyes so just have your Bitcoin
and never use them just keep them
because the idea is Outlook because
bitcoin's only 12 years old right so as
time goes by they'll be more
acceptability
the only thing that's happened over the
last 12 years is you have more people
gambling with Bitcoin I don't go into
any stores where they're taking Bitcoin
no prices no goods and services are
priced in Bitcoin Bitcoin is no more
used as a medium exchange or unit of
account today it's not pricing
it was at one
one again you think you think you think
I'm going to go down to the shops get
some bread and it's going to be priced
in Golda I think there will be plenty
plenty of uh Merchants when there's a
lot of inflation people either they'll
price it in gold or they'll price it in
a currency that's backed by gold the
world has been on a gold standard for
thousands of years there have been
pockets of time where the world has
experimented not on as Grand a scale as
right now but individual countries have
gone off the gold standard gone to Fiat
the currency has collapsed and they go
back to gold right everybody always goes
back to Gold because gold works it's the
best money that we've invented as you
know as men men gold is being used for
thousands of years and that's absolutely
right it has all the way back to Moses
you know that they were using gold then
but we live in this new digital world
where everything is digital and I think
we need money which can cater to that
for example I went for lunch the other
day and um I was getting the menu and
the menu was a QR code on my phone so
the menu is now digital entirely on my
phone I'm reading books I'm using
Kindles I'm not putting vinyls in that's
true everything is digital now so we
let's let's finish this is also we're
just finished the analogy so you went
and had lunch did you have digital food
or real food of course they had real
food exactly so money needs to be real
too right you can't just replace gold
with digits and claim you have digital
gold any more than I can eat a digital
sandwich and and and say I just had
lunch right or I'm living in an actual
house there can be a digital house can't
live in it can't keep me warm right I'm
not going to get any shelter out of a
digital house so there's some things
that have to be real how are you going
to get this huge adoption when you have
when it has such bad reputation all
around the world great question so
that's sort of implying that it's a
Ponzi scheme essentially because it's
like well if nobody needs it and
everybody pulls out pyramid pyramid or
right for sure right but they doesn't
need all these investors
survive because the fundamental utility
is still there money which is
non-confiscation it's not money well it
is money because money is something
which is
with that gold on the other hand is
totally confiscatable people have been
confiscating gold since the dawn of time
whether it's Franklin Franklin D
Roosevelt you didn't cop Escape I
literally read about it I was reading
all about it yeah but literally said to
people that you force them to sell their
gold below the below the market I don't
know so what Roosevelt did is he issued
an executive order and he said if you
have gold you have to turn it in right
right
excuse me I don't want you to turn in my
goal this is my goal right but most my
money I am a sovereign individual why
are you telling me what I can and can't
do with my morning miss the government
right but a lot of people didn't turn in
their gold and nothing happened to them
it's not like the government I don't
want to take that risk that's like it
was like that's like you don't have to
pay your taxes oh that's like you pay
your taxes but I'm not gonna pay my
taxes and hopefully nothing happens the
government didn't send troops
door-to-door they're looking for gold
look gold was horrified gold is very
hard to confiscate because you can't if
I have no they can knock on the door
you may have a warranty
on your oil gold is I'm going to take
you to jail okay all right I have a
warrant for your arrest tell me where
your Bitcoin is well we think you do
okay go look for it well how they're not
gonna find my gold either of course they
can of course they can they can look so
they can't it's physical and it exists
well isn't isn't your Bitcoin stored on
something physical you have like a flash
drive or even if you wrote down your
seed phrase on a piece of paper there's
not on this piece of paper it's in my
head oh your whole your whole seed phase
is in your head yes because I understand
what it means to be a sovereign
individual I do need to take that like
so then what if you forget it
maybe that's where my goal is too right
next to your your seed phrase your goat
isn't a vault we know you'll go do you
know where my gold is the government
that's real value that's worth more than
your Bitcoin well it's not and I I can't
get a cup of coffee with this I can't
run a business with this I can't well
you could you could sell it and you can
go buy but I wouldn't I would you know
use other gold but but if you want to
buy Bitcoin coffee you have to sell your
Bitcoin to buy your coffee
right now there are of course uh these
um intermediaries which allow that
exchange yeah but you can do that you
can eventually as mass adoption grows
but yeah how do you know it's going to
grow because it's already happening no
it's not it is no it's not you can go to
New Hampshire like I said and you can
buy coffee There Are Places yeah maybe
you can spot except coffee yeah maybe
you can find a lone coffee shop it's
owned by some Bitcoin fanatic that is
like you know oh I'll take Bitcoin and
maybe every once in a while some other
Bitcoin fanatic happens to visit that
coffee shop and they do a deal uh but
it's very rare that it's happening and
it's you know I would say personally
fewer companies probably are marketing
that they take Bitcoin than they were in
2017. we're in a bear market right now
well we've been in the bear market for a
couple years but yes we have we got
we're in a bull market last year that's
yeah that that that's over that's long
gone of course but as as time goes by
we'll continue to I think the bull
market will come back well yeah we might
be in a bull market when Bitcoin goes
from 5 000 back up to 10 000 but it's
all going to be part of the overall bear
Market because then it'll go from 10 000
down to one thousand and then maybe
it'll go from one thousand up to three
thousand oh it's a bull market and then
it goes from 3 000 to 300 right and you
know you but we're we're headed lower
right that it's the market has peaked
and and now it's just about how much
longer does it take for the rest of the
air to come out of this bubble you know
I'm gonna paraphrase Elon Musk Elon Musk
says something really interesting and
it's kind of um a touchy subject so just
bear with me the way I tried to
paraphrase this he basically said that
death is good right the reason he said
that death is good is because
um it allows new ideas to come that's
what he said okay I know it's a little
harsh but that's what he said so back to
the coffee shop example right now yeah
it's only Bitcoin Fanatics that accept
Bitcoin um at these coffee shops I agree
with you but as this new generation who
really understands digital technology
gen Z my my
um my generation Millennials as we
become older we approach our 30s our 40s
our 50s we are going to be
doing business in Bitcoin on other
cryptocurrencies right now I actually
pay people on bitcoin well there may be
a lot of people that own Bitcoin now
that may be thinking death is good soon
they may be wishing they were dead uh
but you know literacy we need to teach
people to invest carefully especially
you know with things like gold whatever
you're investing in you need to be
careful that's financial literacy like
my advice for all of you young people
who are about to get wiped out in
Bitcoin right
just use this as a life lesson right the
best part about losing your money when
you're young is that you have a lifetime
to earn it back and to learn from those
mistakes so in the future you don't
repeat them and lose even more money and
so I'm not concerned about Millennials
getting wiped out in Bitcoin I mean okay
you know it's like you know lesson
learned uh and hopefully the people who
you know got went from Fiat paper Fiat
to digital Fiat maybe they'll find
themselves to real money and they won't
forget what they learned about free
market and stuff like that when they
went off on this a bad tangent in in
into into Bitcoin I always think people
should be responsible for their own
financial decisions what people do has
nothing to do with the value and the
utility of Bitcoin so I think it's a
shame when older people get scams I
think my grandparents are getting
scammed right now by some fake Amazon
cooler you know it's unfortunate when
that happens obviously but that has
nothing to do with Bitcoin I could call
an old person up and say hi I've got
some cheap gold for you and you know
then what are you going to blame gold
for that no of course not criminal
activity happens and you can't blame the
the vehicle what I think is
fraudulent about Bitcoin is the entire
thing I mean if you if you look at how
Bitcoin is
presented it looks like a coin and it's
gold
right it's meant to look like gold
except it's nothing like gold it's not a
coin it doesn't have a color it doesn't
have any of the metallic properties of
gold it can't be substituted for gold in
any area where gold is used
um how is Bitcoin created it's mine like
you mine gold but you don't mind Bitcoin
you solve a math problem how is that
mining
um calculating I understand so it's all
the terminology is all meant to confuse
people to to get them to believe that
what they're buying is something similar
to Gold when Bitcoin has nothing in
common with gold it's the opposite of
gold well it has a lot in common no it
doesn't yeah of course it does it does
not I would be happy
city was it
no
yeah can you do cross-border payments
with gold no of course not yes I can no
you can't yes I can it's very expensive
are you gonna ship it across the world I
can ship it for free how all I have to
do is have my gold stored and have a and
and you know ship it ship the ownership
transfer the owner the gold doesn't have
to move just my ownership of the goal no
it's not
it's not just because because then it's
basically paper receipts and we're back
to them it's a no it's not a fiat
currency it's real currency because it's
backed by gold well I wanted to say
we're back to what we were doing I want
to make sure that I can I can flee when
I need to fleece just there's a really
important example right I always like to
talk about Nazi Germany I think it's an
amazing example the Nazis were there
they were taking the the valuable
possessions including the gold of Jewish
people right if they had their gold
stored in in Germany that would be a big
problem are they good are they
comfortable fleeing yeah but what if
they had their goals stored in
Switzerland and they just had a digital
well they said it was thought it was it
doesn't matter I know okay we're in
Germany and that and that's bad right so
when they want to flee and go to another
country how on Earth are they going to
do that how are they going to do it well
now though you don't have to do that
exactly because we have Bitcoin
no you can have a tokenized gold you can
own gold in a token form the same way
you own Bitcoin the actual gold can be
in Switzerland it can be in Singapore it
can be in Dubai it can be some place
that you don't live it can be it can be
confiscated and that's a problem but the
market the problem with Bitcoin is the
value can be confiscated because it has
none it's a price what if you're relying
on your Bitcoin hey I've got all this
Bitcoin that's safe but when you go to
want spend it nobody wants it the bubble
has popped you don't know what Bitcoin
is going to be worth in 10 years it may
be worth nothing right there's a very
good chance that it won't have any value
I mean maybe I'm wrong and maybe it will
go off there's a chance but there's no
chance that gold is going to be
worthless in 10 years it's just not
going to happen I don't I don't know
well why would it be I don't know all I
know is that people people would say oil
would have no value um people would say
oil always have value and then the March
2020 crash happened and it was trading
at negative prices I don't know well it
still has you know I don't know what not
really because needed oil because we're
all locked down so I don't know what
blacks want to vent right but that was
that was oil that was only physical oil
for delivery at that moment in time but
if you looked at oil prices for a year
forward they were still positive they
were only negative if you because people
had to store it and people had no place
to put it right and so if you got stuck
with physical oil and you had no place
to put it so people were paying people
to take the oil off their hands because
that was a Confluence of events that
temporarily depressed oil but obviously
oil was cheap if you could have if you
had a place to put it and and someone
paid you thirty dollars a barrel to
store oil it's ninety dollars a barrel
now you made a lot of money buying cheap
oil but there is no cheap Bitcoin
because no matter how low the price is
it's still overpriced
that's your opinion I think and I really
think Bitcoin will be here in 10 20 30
years to come I think we're moving into
a new digital world and as um we see
more government intervention I think the
purpose of Bitcoin will become more
apparent to people rather than just
gambling like a casino I think for me
the most important part is sovereignty
the fact that I can flee any lockdown
when it happens the fact that you don't
know how much I own nobody can see
anything and it's that being that
sovereign individual I think it is more
powerful when it comes to bitcoin than
it is with gold I still think gold is
very valuable you know I don't I'm not
looking to push gold down but I but I do
see value in Bitcoin and I think that
um I think that you will one day too do
you own Bitcoin uh no I don't have a
Bitcoin
um and I have no you haven't earned any
Bitcoin I did own some for a while that
was gifted to me but I lost the password
and so they're gone they're so they
still exist you just what you just
weren't being responsible with your C
program well the person who actually set
my wallet up never even told me the
seats ways and never told me the
password all I had was the pin and I
knew the pin but all of a sudden my
wallet stopped accepting my pin and
that's what I thought was my password so
that was my first one I didn't give it
to you was it was it on an exchange in a
it was in a wallet called
um
those are called block
um uh crypto I forget it was Eric
Voorhees and his buddy they set up the
company I had a debate with him in SoHo
in New York and then we went out to
dinner and he gave me like 100 bucks
worth of bitcoin or 50 bucks worth of
bitcoin and over time other people just
gave me some Bitcoin so I never bought
any but I ended up with like a third of
a Bitcoin that's that's what I had and
so you know I have no access to it but
you know
it's a video it would have been nice if
I would have sold it and got some money
out of it but well I can help you get
access to it
it goes back up when this one goes back
up straight to the Moon you'll be even
richer no no it's it's not going to the
Moon
um it's coming back down the Earth you
know and in fact it may be buried deep
beneath the Earth but you may be with
all that extra gold you may be right
though about digital I mean digital is
revolutionary and you know it could
transform our monetary system gold could
be the basis of digital money I believe
that you know there's 21
000 altcoins
though I'm not interested in no coins
but what the hell's the difference
what's the difference between them and
Bitcoin limited supplies
some of them have limited Supply well
some of them are backed by VCS the
technology is terrible but you could
just cause a lot of them have better
technology than Bitcoins some of them oh
because what they do is they sacrifice
um the security for efficiency so they
have bigger block sizes and that's
really dangerous I'm happy with
sacrificing certain types of efficiency
in order to have the best level of
security but you think but you think
nobody is going to come up with a better
Bitcoin than Bitcoin I'm open to it yes
then your Bitcoins are worthless because
now everybody wants something better
we'll see if something better comes
along and then you're screwed when it
does not necessarily not necessarily but
I think we'll have to agree to disagree
you are Mr Bitcoin sorry you are missed
the gold I have missed Miss Bitcoin to
agree to disagree that yeah well there
are a few other missed Bitcoins I've run
into a few of them but um I don't think
you're gonna have to wait for somebody
to come along that's better than Bitcoin
I think Bitcoin will self-destruct on
its own before that happens so uh you
know it's not going to be like a long
term you know you don't have to wait
much longer okay I look forward to
having this conversation again in a few
years and I hope that your gold is not
confiscated I hope nothing is
confiscated of yours so that you can
remain a sovereign individual because
that's really important well I've had
things confiscated but not my goals yeah
no I understand I'm gonna get into that
but uh yeah I want to thank you so much
for coming on and where can people where
can people you know follow your work see
what you're doing and I have a podcast
the Peter Show podcast so people can go
to shiftradio.com they can go to my
YouTube channel
and you know listen to the podcast there
if they want to get some gold you know
shift gold right that's they can use
Bitcoin to buy if they want it because
yeah well we all we enable you to sell
your Bitcoin so you can buy some gold
yes pizza I want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure I think we
have to agree to disagree
um and I'm sure we'll have another
conversation of five years where Bitcoin
is much higher probably sooner than five
years
um and then we'll pick it up then all
right thank you so much thank you so
much for watching please don't forget to
hit the like button and hit subscribe so
you never miss a video we'll see you all
next week